the first count against the accused gun
one is one of murder how do you plead
not guilty my lady ice cream I said get
the fun of mast get the mass and I set
over Eva and I cried on analog did you
take an adjournment
pixel nuts off to the brain but it's
like a zombie stuff
I'd like to apologize and say that means
not a moment and hasn't been a moment
since since this tragedy happened that I
haven't thought about your family I wake
up every morning in the first people I
think of the first people are praying
for I can't imagine the pain and the
sorrow and the emptiness that I've
caused you and your family I was simply
trying to protect your Eva I can promise
that when she went to bed that night she
felt loved
if you that it is that yes
keep now my I would leave of the court
asked that the shoulder height of the
colonel be measured as he stayed because
you make contact with me with a
price-weighted
mr. Pistorius did not suffer from a
mental defect or mental illness at the
time of the commission of the offense
that would have rendered him criminally
not responsible for the offenses charged
mr. Pistorius please stand up
having regard to the totality of this
evidence in this matter he is found
guilty of culpable homicide